well that's Alex Crawford for us in
danipra now I'm joined in the studio by
the defense and security analyst
Professor Michael Clarke uh hello again
Michael to you both sides inevitably
blaming each other what's your read yes
Ukraine's got nothing to gain from this
whatsoever I mean it's all bad for
Ukraine um the Russians have got
something to gain from it because
militarily by um blowing part of the dam
creating a downstream problem it makes
it very difficult for the ukrainians to
cross the river we were thinking last uh
November December when ukrainians took
uh Kirsten oblast that west of the river
that the Russians might do this and
there look to be some preparations to do
it it didn't happen looks as if it's
happened now and as we speak I mean most
of the water from the dam the the
stamina could be reaching person as we
speak that's a big important city
they'll be re receiving the peak of the
water now and then we'll see how much
water empties out of the dam it may not
be quite as bad as it looks because it
looks pretty dramatic but we don't know
that the dam hasn't been breached but
the top of it has gone so the water in
the reservoir behind it will drop to
wherever level the the damage has gone
to now it might be that it's weakened
the dam so the dam then does breach we
don't know but looking at it it looks as
if an explosion has taken place near the
top of the dam it's certainly taken out
the roadway and it's it's going to bring
the water level down in a small amount
of water in such a big Reservoir is an
enormous amount of water but it it may
not be that the reservoir will empty
completely we don't we won't know until
we see where the water Settles
when you look at the images you realize
what a monolithic piece of
infrastructure this is and this hasn't
been caused you were saying that by
explosion this hasn't been caused by a
bit of Rogue shelling has it for sure
not no there are no artillery shells in
the world that can do that to a dam you
know this is all reinforced concrete
yeah the dams for a reason if you like
but it'll just put some Puck marks on
it'll scratch it that you can only do
this to a dam if you place explosives
right up against it in some way or other
and you've got to have quite powerful
explosives and this explosion remember
took place on the Russian side of the
dam the the side of the roadway and the
dam that the Russians occupy the
ukrainians are on the other side of it
the Russians are on this side of it and
so you know what happened there in my
own mind I'm absolutely certain it was
the Russians they looked as if they're
about to do this last Autumn we thought
they might try to do it they've
obviously done it once they've seen the
Ukrainian offensive begin and it gives
them a little bit of a military
Advantage at quite a big civilian cost
now we've been watching for the
Ukrainian counter-offensive and for the
first time we've been hearing that there
have been gains of kilometers rather
than just a few meters how serious are
the implications of this because it
makes it trickier to cross the river
doesn't it it does I mean ukrainians
have been pushing all along the front
and the way the Russians are really
worried is zaparesia they're really
worried about a southern push so this is
in a sense part of the thinking behind
that but I think there are lots of
implications one is the humanitarian
implication I mean a lot of Farmland is
going to be ruined there's a lot a lot
of disruption to hydroelectric power and
so on there's also the the uh the north
Crimea Canal which is a canal that runs
from just Upstream of the dam right into
Crimea and Crimea takes most of its
water from that Canal so that water is
going to diminish to some degree we
don't know how much but it will to some
degree diminish and the Crimean people
800 000 of whom are Russians all take
tributaries off the canal for their
normal water supply 200 million liters a
day go down that Watercourse for Crimean
water now it's said that the Crimean
population have filled their reservoirs
in anticipation of something like this
but that will only go so far so this is
going to cause a problem to the Russians
in Crimea as well as anybody else on the
way the other thing in case you were
wondering is yes it's a war crime
um James cleverley the British foreign
secretary said he said it is a war crime
and if you want to know the particular
article this is article 56 of the 1977
additional protocol to the Geneva
Convention and it could have been
written for this case it could have
actually I was reading this earlier this
morning actually overnight and it could
have been written for this namely dams
Dykes nuclear electrical Generating
Station shall not be made the objects of
attack even when these objects are
military objectives in other words this
is regarded as a weapon of mass
destruction because it has an
indiscriminate and disproportionate
effect on civilian population ipso
Factor whoever did this has committed
yet another War crime